and push to
dissolve
thanks for joining us tonight on eight
news now as we spend the next half hour
honoring black history month i'm bianca
holman we're going to share with you
exciting things that are underway right
here in our community and the nation
meant to celebrate and advocate we start
tonight with the impact of dr martin
luther king jr right here
does all to be if we don't understand
our history then we can't move forward
to for las vegas councilman cedric creer
history is everything he was born and
raised in the historic west side and has
seen its change much of that change is
inspired by the work of dr martin luther
king jr knowing
the history of las vegas
knowing that it was a very segregated
city it wasn't until 1960 with the
signing of the moulin rouge agreement
that we desegregated the las vegas strip
i know dr king came here often to one
minute
you know people's rights uh fight for
equality and we need to understand that
and recognize that leading up to
targeting mr king junior day and days
after there are events celebrating her
legacy of one of america's greatest
civil rights leaders leaders want to
ensure the valley's black history is
preserved the historic west side legacy
park was recently revealed located on
mlk and lake mead it honors 36
trailblazers and more
throughout the years this park is just
the beginning of all the work planned
for the area the landscape of the surf
west side in the next five to ten years
will be completely different to what it
is now i think we'll have advanced 20
seconds and our housing
development that are taking place we'll
have more restaurants we'll have other
businesses taking place there are more
plans to re-energize the neighborhood by
making it look beautiful and hiring the
people who live there construction
next to the historic west side school
will begin later this year mike bianco
pushed to dissolve to two
and we mentioned the historic website
here's our whole scene it was dedicated
in december it serves as a tribute to
the many trailblazers who have led the
community through the years it includes
the stories of dozens of leaders that
have had a lasting impact mayor carolyn
goodman was among the many leaders
it is wonderful
24 seconds is
has to understand this
you owe the grandparents and the great
pam grandparents and everybody that's no
longer
maybe in a better place but five seconds
shine like it never has before like
bianca push
one thing that's in place now five west
side is an agricultural park and frank
the local flames central places program
got underway in june of last year the
location in the historic west side was
one of 13 locations in the country for
the program many say this is a
springboard for other good things to
sound to me
state and regional experts to develop a
community-led action plan to strengthen
the local food system
so you can't look at the history of
african americans here in las vegas
without looking back at the moulin rouge
scene the casino hotel
in 1955 when casinos on the strip were
segregated legendary performers such as
sammy davis jr nat king cole lewis
armstrong and harry belafonte took the
stage there
it also started a civil rights meeting
in march in 1960 that led to the
beginning of the end of segregation in
hotels and casinos tuned to
you know dancing package emotions
they communicate
it's an important artistic expression in
the black community the contemporary
west dance theater in las vegas is
preserving it
and dissolved
it's the same thing 250 packages you're
standing in a wing and about to go on
and i'm like this
oh
dancing is freedom
dancing gives purpose dancing gives
truth you don't have a cg time to look
simple and to
you know have my
work
match the quality of the artist that i
have dancer and choreographer bernard
gaddis and ballerina charmaine hunter
created contemporary west dance theater
in 2007. you cannot have
or call it a major city
without having the arts in it the fine
arts
you know and it's different the fine
arts is what trains
these people to be in all of these huge
shows gaddis began his career as a
teenager
pennsylvania
for me it is very important uh
to not only have a diverse and cultural
you know organization
but to also give the opportunity for
people of color to experience dance in
its highest form contemporary west dance
theater educates and helps to advance
multicultural artists the group performs
work
videographers
when you pulled your leg around into
second you want to make sure you that
new music is that
company member zoe sloan has been
dancing since she was two her movement
came naturally because her mother lana
love was one of the only black show
girls on the las vegas shrimp during the
80s and 90s she was in jubilee she was
in aladdin
emerald city
she was used a little chocolate thing
from our superstars
one minute i cried
when when he was dancing because i felt
the pain that he was was projecting
and at that moment then i was like man i
want to be a part of this contemporary
blends ballet and modern dancing giving
sloan wings
i feel like i'm flying when you're on
stage you could channel all your your
sadness or all your anger happiness so
like any emotion that you are trying to
pursue through that
and you could go from 30 seconds fingers
to your toes and you just get this burst
of adrenaline it's it's life-changing
this diverse performing arts company
strives to move people bernard he sees
who you are really and he wants you to
continue one person for yourself every
city has a heartbeat
and the ten seconds let's stand by two
and bianca's mike
is next there is a rhythm five seconds
and through that rhythm it's dance mike
bianca dissolved two
still ahead pull two bring in your music
stand by the community and this team is
stepping and clapping its way towards
and racking up awards along the way
we'll be right back killer mike
2 19 12 19
12 19. nice nice package and nice block
i said nice package and nice block
all right she'll be at verts one and two
okay
no bump no bump
jared you can play that uh tease music
here at the top as a stinger
thank you
so now bump straight up to camera three
with bianca's mic and your music i'll
have her name cg1
it's belleaza
belliesa mary jane belliesa
okay
standard bye
and in
five
four
three
two
one fade up thank you welcome back one
local dance team is navigating through
the image with the community involvement
and with each other they were also
recently honored at the martin luther
king junior day breakfast awards
ceremony mary jane bellassa stairs
they're priceless the priceless diamonds
that's their name
they're making their way through let's
do that one more time belliesa
bellies think yay like yay happy belgia
me too
all right
one more time
standing by
and
and in five
four three
two
one fade up like cure welcome back one
local dance team is navigating their way
through the pandemic with community
involvement with each other they are
also recently honored at the martin
luther king junior breakfast awards
ceremony mary jane belliesa shares how
priceless diamonds that's their name
they're making their way through the
community
okay
tracy's going to change the script real
quick
i changed it and prompted for you too
yeah that's much better
okay
scanner bye
and in
five
four
three
two
one fade up my q push three welcome back
one local dance team is navigating their
way through the pandemic with community
involvement and each other recently
honored at the martin luther king junior
breakfast awards ceremony mary jane
belliesa shares the story of the
priceless diamond and dissolved to me
for the priceless diamonds majorette
dance team every step and every clap
shows unity and the power of teamwork
dance director melissa ross started
priceless diamonds in august 2015. she
wanted to dancehall
i just you know involved more kids to
come and join when i first started mom
stephanie felton says the group
instantly became a family from the start
i was literally there with her on the
bed when she came up with colors a name
and her recruitment and i was in her
first studio actually and their talent
definitely shows so far the team has
over 90 trophies even winning best
community dance group at this year's
martin luther king jr parade but
assistant secretary mandisha shanks says
kova 19 has brought on financial
struggles making it hard for them to
travel to competitions we do
acts for
donations or sponsorships it's been real
hard over the years because background
cameras
so it's been
coming out of the pockets of the parents
and the director
says it hasn't been easy but is proud of
everything they've accomplished so far
people you know go and come and kids
growing up on the team since they was
like real little
diamonds isn't slowing down anytime soon
even through this pandemic the team
credits their brotherhood sisterhood and
perseverance to get themselves
everybody be like how you do it
god
five seconds
god sent by eugene
live local now bianca dissolved three
pushups turning to another art
award-winning songwriter curtis mayfield
left his mark in musical history and now
his son is working to make a movie out
of his father's story mayfield's lyrics
were unique resonating
as war was raising in vietnam and the
civil rights movement brewing in the u.s
his music became the anthem for the
movement oftentimes it was so
controversial that many radio stations
refused to play his records mayfield's
life is reflected in more than 800 songs
he wrote throughout his career
the 1970 multi-million dollar selling
soundtrack for the black exploitation
film superfly tuned
so who doesn't love a good cup of coffee
i know i do you may have seen
this brand black and bold on store
shelves and there's a message and
there's a grind pernell cesar and ross
and now
roast pack and ship it to retailers
across the country since launching in
2018 the pair have sold more than 275
000 bags and signed on with major
retailers including wholesale
target and amazon i don't wipe to sound
anything
31 seconds uh so it represents the
contents the products that are in the
bag black coffee black tea bowl
flavoring um but it also reminds me of
as entrepreneurs as people right 20
seconds left black men who are on a
journey to make a real difference the
shift in the national conversation has
really 10 seconds
into our ecosystem um and we're hoping
that we know right now that we have
their attention
with something that's embedded in their
daily rituals
bianca five percent of their profits are
given
across the country to three pull through
just ahead a look at how crucial of a
role mothers blame the civil rights
movement
killer mike
and
mike
so we've long heard about the great
civil rights activists martin luther
king jr malcolm x but have you ever
stopped to think about their mothers
reporter christy gross has a story
dissolved i got excited about the
concept of telling the story
when anna maleka tubbs began looking
into the mothers of some of the most
notable civil rights icons she found
their influence activism and
contributions to history largely
before i found out it was so obvious
that there were direct connections
between each of the sons i'm gonna kill
the viewer just do a quick
how the mothers of martin luther king jr
malcolm x and james baldwin shaped a
nation as she became a mother herself
tubbs says she identified with the women
in some ways as a black woman and as the
wife of former stockton mayor michael
tubbs i so often in my own personal
experiences was referred to as the woman
behind the great man which i really
didn't find to be a compliment you know
i'm right there beside him i'm not
behind him you know we just have to pay
more attention
to women of color the biography takes
readers through the lives of alberta
king louise little and burtis baldwin
movements do not just pop out of nowhere
they don't just start with one person
it's a part of this generational passing
of knowledge this is our hope time has
changed it is occurring all over the
globe tubbs believes
three women
but it is a complete crime to erase the
fact that his mom was also an organizer
and even after her husband is murdered
by a white supremacist group
she continues her activism in the book
she lays out how each woman influenced
their famous sons who we still revere
today i even have letters in the book
where malcolm x thanks his mother for
everything that she taught
activism and his approach to black
freedom scholar activist wife and mother
anna maleka thomps hopes her book will
inspire others to flesh out the
contributions of other women who have
been relegated to the footnotes of
history
erasure
and this kind of disregard of our lives
it has much much to do with how we value
women of color five
that i'm seconds
can and continue to change
mike bianca push three and dissolve to
three now from strong mothers to strong
family packages one woman has made a
life's work to showcase black families
after she says they're often
misrepresented here's a story from our
sister station in iowa and it's all to
see
okay you ready 241 package
one two count cue each other and
shooting
when keisha ward points her camera
[Music]
it's hard not to smile they love it i
love it and it just makes the work that
i do so much more easier okay my love
it's behind the lens at her studio in
valley junction where her purpose comes
into focus i love to capture
the intimacy
behind the camera i love to capture
the loviness that happens between
families between them
she's snapped thousands of photos
capturing yeah
highlighting what it means to be black
and proud from black women empowerment
to motherhood and boldness it was it was
also about
empowering
it was about
knocking the scene learning you know and
things like that and making them feel
comfortable and for folks to see that
she believes celebrating black love is
worth capturing too it's why the finleys
are stepping in front of the camera and
it almost feels like black love isn't
the norm
but i think it is more normal than we
think and it's because we don't see it
commonly that a lot of people don't
think it exists but we're here they say
representation of couples who look like
them in the media can sometimes be seen
stereotypical dysfunctional even broken
not enough showcasing a love that can
last i graduated from high school 30
years ago he was at my high school
graduation the williams are recreating
their love story after 30 years of
friendship we've been friends a long
time and we've celebrated our black love
for a long time and that's really what
it is it's our glue
and we don't make apologies for that
that's why with every shot it feels
powerful 30 seconds every angle
each other i think gives people a lot of
hope that it can happen for them like
both of you have natural
smiles 20 seconds is a picture that
tells a much bigger story you think of
not just black love but strong black
love successful black lives matter
seconds stand by three and beyond this
mike and you're fine
right five seconds
communication
successful and the way you love on each
other like bianca dissolved in three
bring your music playing the ladder of
opportunity that's next and fate black
okay
yeah what you got
okay
it should be okay
a two and a half
it's true um hey listen we've got 301
left on the clock i've got this down to
304 so just read me quick and we should
be fine
heck yeah and then talk to them don't
even get me started about
like yeah it was just tough to even have
the staff to get stories for this
perfect
all right so no bump no bump straight up
to camera two with bianca's mic and your
stinger music
i'll have her name
all right standard bye
stand by
okay
and in
five
four
three
two one fade up my cube finally tonight
honoring our african-american first time
packaging beat the mcintyres dissolved
you know how some days things just
magically seem to go your way from tick
tock 243
youtube
life with the mcintyre certainly has its
fun and fabulous moments
[Music]
who initially made their name on social
media is quickly becoming a picturesque
example of your copyright for major
companies
[Music]
the duo made of wife shantae a full-time
influencer and husband michael who
spends most of his time away from the
camera in front of a different type of
bright light
and i make sure that we get the call
safe mcintyre works as an engineer for
the fresno fire department the engine
would come screaming down the street but
not seeing a face that looked like him
gave him doubts being a kid from
inglewood i didn't think that that was a
possibility for me after playing college
basketball he started to think about a
career it was firefighting 2005 he got
his shot mcintyre understands the
gravity of what it means for the
community to see him in a uniform
there's been times where i've been out
on a fire or even at the store we go to
the store we grocery shop
and i will be walking past somebody and
usually like it's an older black woman
or black man and they would look at me
and they'll give me the head not like
fellow firefighters like deandre douglas
may have had a less public face but the
motivation to join was just as valiant
raised in clovis he recalled being
inspired to protect this community after
seeing firefighters on 9 11. there were
people running into that building to
help those people while people were
trying to get out if it's a commercial
structure no more this big inch and
three-quarter line duties carried out
during his 14-year long career
douglas recalls not seeing a firefighter
until later in life i was an adult when
i first when i saw my first firefighter
black firefighter several black
firefighters from his family's church
heard of his interests and reached out
to him to help him through the process
for captain willie johnson sergio had
always been a family business his dad
served in the military and his son now
works for the l.a county sheriff he
recalls his first exposure to the 30
seconds one summer when he woke up
with the music the most fun
copyright growing up we didn't go
camping he still remembers the moment he
got the call don't play with me i just
want you to know i want to scream right
now but i'm sitting at my desk so i
can't but i am very happy trust me i'm
happy for this offer yes still excited
nearly 10 seconds later
next generation walk into a fire and
there's these two little kids standing
there and one of them just starts
hitting his buddies like oh my god we
got black firefighters mike biancon
bringing your music thanks for staying
with us i'm bianca holman good night and
song
really nice job guys thank you